hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast please
take a second to subscribe to the
YouTube channel that way you get the
episodes as they come out thanks a lot
welcome to another exciting edition of
ru garbage the show where you find out
if your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage the show where we sit down
with your favorite comedians and find
out if they grew up classy or if they
grew up trash
I'm your host H Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day beautiful day here in
Astoria Queens my co-host hot tail out
of town the first sign of trouble when
the rona came to town he's at an
undisclosed location somewhere in
southern New Jersey his mom's house give
it up for Kippy Kevin James
Araya my mom's vacation house it pays to
have a little bit of case you know what
I mean
[Laughter]
new money baby death here in South
Jersey living it up playing it right you
know funnel cake all day riding the
ferris wheel the swings maybe log flume
whatever you need I'm your guy thanks
for listening everybody please take a
quick second to subscribe to the YouTube
channel and iTunes you can rate review
we appreciate all the comments
everything like that and please tell a
[ __ ] friend about that every
nice thank you can't be our very very
special guest today we're so excited to
have them kind of been a mentor to us
going all the way back to the West
Village days here in New York City he is
an accomplished and very funny stand-up
comedian you've seen him on wild and out
joking off difficult people the leftover
Startalk vidiots clickbait guy code guy
code versus girl code
all right and he is the co-host of the
amazing podcast flagrant two ladies and
gentlemen the one the only mr. Akash
Singh that is the most thorough list of
credits I've ever gotten to the point
that it makes me seem way more
successful
hahaha I heard a couple of those I'm
like I don't even I'm like fully might
be [ __ ] juice in this list to Betty
three lines on difficult people I don't
even remember some of you have a star
crossed the Neil deGrasse Tyson show I
mean it's like fake click fit you were a
narrator for 20 episodes that must have
brought in a couple of fossils you know
what I mean that was great I saw that I
was sliding off my seat I was like 5 6
TV shows 2018 one by one they all just
got canceled and it's one of the most
like sad like falls from grace I've ever
seen and I was it was mine it's always
sad when you're in it regardless of how
bad it is Oh
one by one I was like I still got all
these shows and then that one would be
gone I still got forward that was good
then by some point I was just there with
nothing over the course of nine months
look we all got E now we all got nothing
baby to a degree
no I caches I see him they're breaking
the social distancing rules him in
[ __ ] you guys are still recorded
episodes in the central personnel were
media yeah right [ __ ] out of here
all over it Schultz studios talking
about because it'd be bigger than MTV in
six months you'll be buying MTV in six
months thank you man is that me cheap
right now nobody's watching by a cow
yeah so you definitely get your hands on
Comedy Central I do it a lot I'll just
sell a special them and pretend I did it
on my own yeah they're perfect no
executive at get Comedy Central mr. case
Ross oh hello Joe he brings all the
squat in everybody's runnin chin buddy
buddy show's canceled I'm sorry thanks I
was thinking about doing this show buddy
go nuts that's good good stuff Akash for
surviving over here on the on the
podcast want to find out a little bit
about you grew up I know you're a
Cowboys fan technically this show would
be over there because you're [ __ ]
garbage all right and we could say that
as Eagles fans okay anybody
if anybody can judge other fans its
Eagles fans for sure you guys are pure
class yeah if you think I've never been
to a wedding in Philadelphia and people
start a chant
the Cowboys I mean yeah for sure that
happens
multiple times remember how there was
one scene in silver linings playbook
where a Philadelphia fan who was brown
got beat up for being brown by other
Philadelphia fans and honestly this give
these guys an F I could just I don't
know how things get more realistic yeah
dude that's that's some real [ __ ] that
is real [ __ ] filling is it my my wife
is future wife is from Philly her
daddy's an Eagles fan but he's seasick
he wears the Pug the bug the turban so I
want to take him to a game but like I
definitely won't here for the Cowboys if
the cowboy game I'll be quiet as [ __ ]
but sure man I'm worried about these
animals yeah you would you should be
alright if you put it easy he can he can
wear that you know he can wear the hat
but he also has to wear jersey if he
wears a whens jersey the most racist
thing I thought in that scene was the
people that were defending to brown
people when it when the right was the
fight was starting in civilized public
the one guy yelled hey man leave the
Indians alone and the way he said more
racist of the guys want to beat them up
that's a sweet this really can be yeah
that's an ally in Philly that dude that
dude should run for [ __ ] mayor I'm
filling the thing that I think is
garbage is when and I understand it but
when people are fans of and it's all
silly but when people are fans of teams
where they didn't grow up yes always on
trustworthy I can't trust you as a
[ __ ] person he's like yeah if you
like their name of your town or nothing
that's all you get
yeah yeah it's like a me the guy from
Jersey is it I'm really it the [ __ ]
the San Diego Chargers like [ __ ] Annie
always have like some [ __ ] stories
and well my dad went up on a business
trip to San Diego one time and you
really like the pizza six cut the [ __ ]
up no you're bad judge of character
that's like Chris cotton was it was the
biggest 49ers fan we used to make fun of
them because they were terrible
the last time he remember cotton was
cotton was a [ __ ] 49ers fan maybe
like what define a [ __ ] to your kids
from black kid from South Philly 49ers
before Kaepernick it wasn't like a
Kaepernick thing oh yeah yeah years
years before that and he was too young
to remember Montana and then I could
kind of give it to you
either way garbage doesn't matter
so you grew up in Dallas a year your
parents did your parents come here I'm
68 I think she was 14 that's for the
listed age she actually doesn't know her
real birthday at all that's a wild but
she she was 14 she was somewhere between
14 and 18 and she came here and then
when she my dad and her got an arranged
marriage he came over and he was 24/7
and they they went to distrait to Dallas
Dallas I don't understand I think my
grandfather lived here for like 10 years
before he brought my mom over and then
at that point he had settled in Dallas
it was cheap he had a job so he brought
them over and then when my mom and dad
got married you're not going anywhere
else yeah yeah for sure and then did you
grow up in like how it was it like a
suburban house dropping ballast kids all
of that yeah single homes our garage
serious questions I know exactly what
you're about to go it does yeah we just
heard immigrated to America arranged
marriage here's the first question go
ahead do you have a garage did you have
a garage fridge growing up no no no
garage friends are bridge you need a
garage fridge it's a garbage not happy
to have a girl no apples in that
refrigerator should be like sodas ice
pops things the year kind of kind of
summer oriented items [ __ ] you talking
about who's hanging out in the garage
you don't hang out in the garage that's
where you store the excess supplies
while she's keeping the regular garage
your poor ass refrigerator you got the
keys
it is kind of trashy and always it's
it's you never buy to garage you never
buy two fridges it's always like an
uncle's or like you find it on the curb
but I know you guys had to do it too
you guys are filling up ice trays every
two days and don't [ __ ] act like you
oh yeah
no I had an icemaker dog ah you piece it
an icemaker in the water spout yeah we
were no money in that in the early 80s
earlier late eighties early nineties
there was a little bit of cage yeah but
here's the thing
Akasha filling up ice trays is classy
the trashy thing is if you've ever had a
bag of ice in your refrigerator
when it wasn't a party can you know you
were [ __ ] garbage oh you said
alcoholic parents waiting are like a
dirty screwdriver [ __ ] hacking at it
I want to go back to this so your
grandfather came here came here first on
your dad's side yeah and then your so
your dad was he grandfather my mom's
side grandfather you know so he was like
trying to get the money up or whatever
story he told us and then when my mom
got married she was visiting and this is
crazy actually she was visiting India
for like a finite amount of time and
they wanted to get her an arranged
marriage to my dad but they had to
decide in like two days my dad even get
to see didn't even know he was getting
married until the day of the wedding
everything had to move so fast she was
like yo she's going back to America
tomorrow or whatever so we got to get
married today
so my dad is that another family members
wedding and another part of the state
and then he's like getting fitted for
wedding clothes on the way there in
India or in America in India and then
that's your life so she's in India right
now you guys are gonna get married
you're both gonna go to America that's
gonna work your life in India as you
know it is oh it's done but it worked
out they fell in love and they like each
other and they're still together and all
that yeah that's [ __ ] nuts that's hard
court was there a big Indian community
in Dallas when you were growing up there
there is now when I was when I was there
they had like a group of friends that I
grew up with that Royal Indian uh-huh I
told me back in the day when you would
see another Indian wherever you were you
would like stop you were doing it go
talk that first time Democrats like they
over here over here let's get coffee
straight up like oh my god where you
from oh my god like imagine being
America American and then moving a
[ __ ] I don't even know yeah
Antarctica essentially because that's
what was like in the 70s 80s but like
wait we saw an American speaking English
you'd be like holy [ __ ] what's going on
who are you
let's be friends they made a circle of
friends it's still from their friends
this day and
all the kids became friends ah I'll date
friends like that and then that's that's
the community I grew up in but your mom
wasn't one your dad wasn't born here
either right correct
so how Americanized was the house
growing up when you were a kid um the
house is Indian my mom's kind of
American because she was 14 she went to
high school here I am like Indian yeah
okay me in the house now they been in
America so long they're speaking out
English cuz they're just he's been here
40 good years I was too it yeah like
yeah I grew up in an Indian house it was
always a weird thing in an Indian house
and then you're outside and everybody's
like what the [ __ ] is Indian and then
you go back to a house it's like I don't
understand America mm-hmm all right this
is gonna be interesting I want to find
that here we go it's still a little
[ __ ] are you garbage it could be are
you garbage where you just raised with
immigrant parents we have to have had an
expert to the name of the name of it I'm
saying I Cash's mom ran ran a tight
clean household there was no garbage in
it
oh she's incredible clean yeah well I
want to go over some basics though was
it was mayonnaise allowed in the house
did you hear Bailey's not off we didn't
eat it a lot but it was there it was the
most all right so are you garbage this
is a question was it Hellmann's
mayonnaise comes a miracle well you know
it is Hellmann's mayonnaise okay
freaking night bringing that [ __ ]
generic [ __ ] - [ __ ] the see how so
what you [ __ ] dick what are you nuts
Foley
all right see hey I was rootin for
elements I just I gotta ask the
questions we gotta be for one way to
make mayonnaise gayer and as mere that's
the blow on it
all right growing up or you guys'd
dominoes or a Pizza Hut family Oh
we were both I was Domino's
my dad was dumb we went Pizza Hut and
then we transitioned at Domino's and I
always hard for Domino's and then I
remember they came out with commercials
a year later they were like we know our
pizza sucks yeah yeah yeah come on I was
in your [ __ ] I was riding with you and
then
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah would you go
to Pizza Hut we will go to Pizza Hut we
sit in the pizzeria when I was a kid
yeah well that's why I always thought it
I always thought Domino's was like new
flashy I thought it was like for like I
don't know I thought Pizza Hut was more
like classic and elegant not that it was
elegant but like you could go to sit
down he's got big get a big sprite and
I've written that read [ __ ] glass
yeah exactly that's what I'm saying you
walked in there it was [ __ ] nice dude
it was garbage but it was awesome going
to Pizza Hut with that wood and yeah the
red cups the crushed ice it was the
[ __ ] buffet sticking out that was
like an actual [ __ ] restaurant for a
little while yeah I don't have cc's did
you all have cc's do the pizza is
already shitty enough pizza right now
Doug Bavarian cream pizza it's just a
pizza crust with bavarian cream on top
and they got cinnamon roll pizza oh
that's [ __ ] garbage that is whatever
the trashy [ __ ] I've ever heard of my
life dude I defy you it used to be a
dollar 69 with a drink all you can eat
and then they raise it to $2.99 without
a drink and I was like are y'all crazy
is this highway race the buffet was to
69 169 for kids I was a kid is also like
20 oh they were for sure cutting some
[ __ ] safety corners that's I thought
Domino's was bad Domino's is like a
crack house cuz you don't you can't sit
in there you just like go top and
[ __ ] go home and get high around yeah
there was never any more 15 to 20 or 25%
of the restaurants in Texas are buffets
really huh okay so Golden Corral Domino
I mean doling where else Cici's Pizza in
there was another one ahead of buffet
pizza hut had a book label into a small
enough town yeah Pete some puff I was
alright though I'm sure there was a
Mexican okay it's just there's buffets
everywhere I always talk about the
buffet at Wendy's I don't know if you
guys are too young to remember that you
were
the buffet at Wendy's now Wendy's is too
dirty inside this this buffet was clay
it's spaghetti they used to make garlic
bread out of the old buns and they had a
killer salad bar I'm telling it they had
like a Mexican stationery station I
would fully stop it yeah he would just
take all the croutons from the salad car
that's the only reason he was going he's
going you got more cars into salad bar I
like salad but I'm talking about a
[ __ ] eighties fast food buffet salad
bar so it was covered in ranch dressing
breaded cheddar cheese all over it and a
slap a chocolate pudding in the [ __ ]
corner yeah come on now being that be
that a Dallas kid are you uh are you
what are you dr. pepper or mr. Pibbs dr.
peppers I'm mr. piggies [ __ ] for
almost said that for the same flagrant -
all right I can't stay in the heat I'm
not Schulte I can't take that heat
yeah this is on Disney Plus don't
[ __ ] screw us over here
I heard here's a garbage where where do
they even sell mr. Pibb
gay voices deep south
fire island
I've never even I've never even seen it
anywhere believe if I was in elementary
school and I went over your house and
you gave me a [ __ ] mr. Pibb I was
flipping the table and walking the [ __ ]
out get out of here but Dad [ __ ] I
like it but it's definitely from the
most racist parts of the deep south if
you're ever in a small town you see
somebody with a can of [ __ ] dr. pips
get back in the car and lock them up I
see yeah I think dr. paid dr. peppers
pretentious do you refer no it's not
pretentious as the standard oh they
think it is never do you refer to it as
soda
I think soda now that I'm in New York
but in the south you call it all coke he
said hey man give me a coke they say
what kind no way like dr. pepper or
sprite or whatever
I thought Pop was bad you hear somebody
say popular pop is hopefully sounds so
Katy is coming out of something yeah
that's Midwest [ __ ] I've never
you never wore shoes before it's like
it's also like how the [ __ ] did like
house how what kind of inbreeding is
going on to where like soda hasn't
penetrated it's soda everywhere else in
the [ __ ] world except like three
states in the Midwest
Allisyn not gone through your [ __ ]
idiot head to start calling it soda all
right here pal I feel like a
twelve-year-old in a diaper like walking
into the kitchen with no shirt oh my
pretentious now that I think about it
like adding the whole extra syllable but
for soda pop is just I don't even know
how you get [ __ ] how much trash man
trash pop is are see you're drinking RC
Cola did you fully speaking of them like
a little bit more but did you uh did you
guys did you ever do generic cereal or
was it was it you know proper name brand
cereal I find it so what was your go-to
cereal I tried you mean Eric cereal I
didn't have a go to any thousand fat
kids so anything sugary I was in for
golden you're a fat kid I was a fat kid
you're about to 160 I was a fat kid big
chipmunk
damn I would have never seen that yeah
as a fat kid so I love there and I still
love everything sugar to this day and my
girl is in fantastic shape but she loves
every kids cereal so people I fight
showed you my cereal thing right now
there's cinnamon toast crunch there's
honey bunches of oats was in that bed
there's Lucky Charms
I made her by crunch berries I house
that whole box mmm just kids good he's
clean now baby that's clean living right
there that's a that's a cabinet full of
love right there and your mom was cool
with this growing up you were allowed to
get sugar cereal you let me do what I
wanted and then at some point I think
she realized that would wise up and not
want to be so fat and usually what
happens yeah but she was the one going
to the store so she wouldn't you know
she would let you get that stuff at the
store yeah she spoiled me my dad thought
I was a [ __ ] and he was probably right
my mom's follow me yeah it's a Tale of
Two Cities right there you were [ __ ]
you weren't real fluff to real hard in
two seconds
oh wow she was great she spoiled me
rotten my dad thought I was a piece of
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
um what about Lunchables were Lunchables
on the menu and they weren't good they
were just trash we tried to protect they
were good I used to get jealous on the
stupid suburb kids the white kids with
the [ __ ] lunch rolls pizza and then I
bought them like a few times to convince
myself but eventually I was like man
this [ __ ] sucks yeah they do suck
you don't already flashed you in the
lunchroom now theta is it's a thing you
know what I mean it's the one thing by
name you know you it's not just your you
have a generic ham sandwich but if
you've got a [ __ ] lunchable that's oh
that's name-brand right like how stupid
or children that you think that's good
it's high now isn't Bologna I know the
only thing that I did like in that realm
was the [ __ ] and we've talked about
this before the handi-snacks rely candy
snacks was the little thing at crackers
with its own cheese that you would peel
back with the Reds you had to go
breadsticks if you want cheese crackers
it was no fun but the bread bread sticks
were [ __ ] good I said remember the
British things the bread sticks came out
a little later for probably older but
then they even went I don't know whoever
thought of this needs a raise they want
pretzel sticks Oh pretzel sticks in the
cheese they came out later in the day
like I was an adult eating those being
like oh these are came out [ __ ] early
90s well they got the adult version of
that which is the sabor pretzels and
hummus yes yes dude I always think of
the same things and it's just a baby
because they're the thin pretzels
they're like almost like your pretzel
skins not too shabby I like that
it's a good time all right all right I'm
getting the picture of a of the standard
suburban childhood here right give a
suburban kid all right what did you what
did your dad do for a living what kind
of work could he do he worked for a
company called Texas Instruments then he
got laid off then he opened vitamin
stores GNC s which is ironic cuz I was
fat and they lost them all then I was
then I lost weight well probably from
the suppressor going broke I don't know
but the point is he that's what we did
and then my mom worked there for a while
but now she's an accountant at an oil
company and I'm my dad does Texas a
couple of dollars signs floating around
through there through the years yeah up
and down but yeah yeah for a little
while we had money that was a sin
with us I was like girl we are on top of
the world oh she had to taking the car
yeah you came back from college one
weekend it's all for sale sign at the
house and I was like [ __ ] dude I had the
same [ __ ] thing my dad's like I'm
just seeing what you get for it I'm like
I think the banks oh my god by the way
of Bank of America cause my name is
Larry dan dan died a couple of weeks ago
that don't call me bad in front of
people would suit son all right
Kibby please did you have a Power Wheels
growing up no man I wanted one like a
[ __ ] but I didn't get one
I had two used where are you that's how
trash that's Gardens red Jeep that was
Elise - power wheels were [ __ ] hot
[ __ ] it was the real it was a real
catch-22 if you got one fresh you were a
[ __ ] prick you're fry here any of my
friends that got one I secretly files I
hope he [ __ ] gets drunk and drives it
off a [ __ ] bridge now garbage you are
you and the other five-year-old you're
drinking
hope he gets pulled over with coke in
the car that son of a [ __ ] he's got a
power wheel know that but if you got one
second hand man because my family like
like where my generation is them having
kids it was finally enough Luke going
around where somebody could get one
second Dan oh there's real you see a
little blond headed kid riding around
and like a faded pink cheap
I had a faded red Jeep it was [ __ ]
mine was like whether to definitely
should've run a Carfax on that [ __ ] it
is definitely a couple of accidents
missing a headlight Power Wheels at age
five is like having a me Bob now yeah
dude that's why I'm [ __ ] upset at the
kids now like you could just get like a
jeep or like that was really it you can
really only get the Power Wheels was
just like a a truck or
gee now they get like Escalades like my
nieces and nephews have like [ __ ]
Escalades and Corvettes and [ __ ] I'm
like yo you [ __ ] new-money
[ __ ] I think I seen at home my
kid has an it to me I've seen you've
seen that
take that to the Tyson Fury fight if I
can pull up in style one of those things
that any of your friends growing up or
did you have a backyard that was on a
slant I did wait your for your family
your friends we built the fence so that
the slant would go away like we we like
built this fence like inward about seven
eight feet 10 feet 12 feet whatever was
and then the slant was outside the fence
but we did have it was like a booty call
like a half a trapezoid or whatever yeah
great and then dropped off a cliff
that's that's pretty garbage because
that's the cheapest house in the
neighborhood you get your parents are
looking for a good looking to shape a
couple of bucks I lay stuff - oh man
steep driveway you go to your buddy's
house eh you want to see the backyard
we'll play you're out there like in
Moonraker [ __ ] you're like what the
[ __ ] is this you gotta throw the ebrake
called in the driveway that's no good
that and the people in the neighborhood
live near the recession pond or whatever
it is you know I'm talking about we're
like just like we're like crazy son you
were you're on the outskirts of town if
you'd be the buyer correct I lived in a
townhouse community for the first four
years we suburbs of Philly that had a
creek running through it did you play in
the creek I look back on times during
like huge storms
we're like the creek would be all
swelled up the water would be rushing
and we were in that thing playing around
like we were in a [ __ ] swimming pool
in the middle of July just like what the
[ __ ] you could have been swept away yeah
God knows where the water was coming
from your trash
yeah if you're swimmin in temporary
temporarily bodies of water that's
[ __ ] garbage unadulterated pure trash
catching crayfish down there dude
stay away from the sewer grate it'll
suck in Folly Philadelphia I'm so like
Foley's even like him there are even
more from the woods like his like the
featherly kind of they haven't have a
twang a mountain people in them so
that's like real garbage
my family was play from poor in the city
and then got a couple of bucks and my
dad was able to get out in the suburbs
well he's coming from the other way he's
getting closer to civilization support a
mountaintop PA no senators coming out of
there I'll tell you that much and hit
with a portable sign when I was five
years old would you say a lot of Trump
signs and mountaintop PA oh yeah all
right um you're I think I think you're
about to say major right your early 30s
mmm 36 on Monday Oh
at any point in your life did you own a
pager I did and I'll tell you what if I
look back on it it really lets me know
how friendless I was your paging
yourself I wanted my mom to page me all
the time yeah oh man there's nothing
nothing worse than a quiet pager you're
just sitting there
you can't play no [ __ ] games on I
can't believe on it there's a decorative
piece I believe I did that can't my mom
did that for me that's how spoiled I was
she let me have a pager for like three
months and then she was fine like nobody
is ever calling you I know man I wanted
the same thing I had one no one my dad
would call my friend's house like
looking for me you know had like [ __ ]
page me dad what the [ __ ] doing I mean
like a real piece of [ __ ] how old were
you when you guys were rocking these
young teens yeah I remember call him I
remember calling dealers on pagers I
never have one on my own I was too
innocent for all that in the idea that
drug dealers use those I didn't even
understand why
sure yeah but Foley was also a Foley
exhausting 22-page in people for [ __ ]
coke he wasn't 13 looking for a dying
bag he was [ __ ] he was he was beef and
Pablo and the [ __ ] Bronx we were
getting into the hard stuff back then
what about lawn decorations no lawn
decorations no lawn decorations swimming
pool I know swimming pool I thought I
wanted one and now my dad not wanting
one I understand so much why he doesn't
want one he was always just like no it's
a waste of money
yeah little maintain a whole year you're
not gonna go swimming as often as you
think you are I'm not doing that even
when we had money when we built a big
house that we the one that we ended up
selling he put that money in toward like
a meteor room which was great
oh that's a [ __ ] thing use that all
the time yeah baby of doing anything
called a media room is classy you first
saw those on MTV Cribs in the early
2000s like this is the media room you're
like I don't you can get beYOU can bet
get bamboos look at a shitty hotel when
you go to their business center though
and it's just [ __ ] like a hotel and a
[ __ ] printer that doesn't print in
color yeah yeah now this was a legit ass
I mean we didn't have like the movie
theater setup or whatever we just had a
couch on the TV but it's like a hundred
thirty-eight inch to the projector and
then watching Golden Girls and my mom
like a [ __ ] that's pretty classy your
mom was a fan of Golden Girls
we both are fans of Golden Girls I'm
good writing it's good someone who's in
the biz we get it yeah
Sophia Beast Rose beast was the big
[ __ ] be flange Blanche Bea Arthur was
the actor the play-doh Bea Arthur was
[ __ ] legit
science side note about that in I live
in Washington Heights and they opened up
a Golden Girls cafe I like a hundred and
ninety at them Broadway and the
Dominicans are like what the [ __ ] is
this and they got them only they only
here got like they shut down because
they got three customers the whole time
yeah there's no way that your [ __ ] yeah
yeah no dude they did it pass the George
Washington Bridge and like where it's
like people barely speak English
yeah you got to do that [ __ ] out of
Miami I know get it crying oh man be
nice a big Miami fan all right do you
guys ever eat off TV trays growing up no
no yeah it's trash all right
did you ever own a pair of LA lights mm
I wanted a pair but I didn't ever get
them I got a pair anybody anybody
wearing LA gear around the house oh you
so love la gear I used to love it like
yeah I got a Payless kissing I like
gears with the lights I think I try to
pretend I didn't think they were cool
but low-key I thought they were so cool
yeah you wanted they were [ __ ] they they
were a hot ticket and when those things
drop [ __ ] Jordan those things were
tight Kippy you got him yeah man I got
him I wanted him so bad and like they
were like sold out like you couldn't get
them [ __ ] anywhere I mean my dad
wants like a couple of malls and then we
finally found a pair I don't know let's
say I was five they were a size like two
they and like I [ __ ] squeeze my foot
in oh my god fits it fits just if I
could buy him I don't think I'm not
wasting my [ __ ] money on this these
clearly don't fit but I end up getting
them at some point i'ts they were hot
for like a year or two yeah okay nights
were [ __ ] tight yeah you guys might
be too old for this but we're either one
of you guys dipping around with the
sneaks with wheels on them I always
thought that was trash not a healing
they came out later but they were
[ __ ] it's like to get a pair of
rollerblades be a man you know when I'm
here those things are weak I gosh you
ever get a haircut from your mom no I
honestly would have been down though I
would have been into it money I was into
as a kid do you ever cut your mom's hair
know that game alright what was your
first car and didn't have a CD player in
it my first car was I bought from my dad
it was a 1993 Honda Civic hatchback
nice love it to this day and I'm yeah
that's a [ __ ] Limit Break I would buy
that exact car if I had unlimited money
why he would lose her mind but I want a
stick shift a little si a little nice
speed thing
loved it I didn't have a second layer it
did have a CD player they got stolen
twice I think in LA yeah CD player in
fact back in the day was it was [ __ ]
nice mm-hmm the hatchback would be
considered garbage but I loved the high
stool I had two hatchbacks growing up
and I [ __ ] loved them
not never be hatchback these days I
liked it because I knew it looked goofy
as a high schooler but now I'm like yo
I'm 36 I'm like there's so much utility
like functional it's very functional
hmm this is how garbage why am I
whatever step-grandfather someone let
somebody my family grandfather garbage
garbage
step-grandfather it's tough it's tough
he froze up there you gotta be that a
step grandfather I also I also do y'all
brought up and I have an ex stepmom how
about that try that one on for size who
he took a run at a couple years ago she
said no but he took a minivan and just
took all the seats out of the back so it
was like a it was like an indoor or
party and it looks like an indoor like
an enclosed pickup truck they would just
like put you in there like that's pretty
smart trashy but smart all those indoor
pools the kids just hang out it's
perfect
all right Foley you got one yeah I'm
curious to know I don't have one
specific but where was the garbage place
to go on a family vacation would you
guys go on family vacations no I think
we're garbage for family vacations so in
the summer you guys never went anywhere
where would where would like to trashy
Dallas families go on a shitty vacation
not a good one probably like one of the
lakes in the area there's like a lake or
a robber it's like a little man-made
Lakes you probably just go to one of
them Lake Texoma
which is it between Texas and Oklahoma
is by one of those spots man-made Lakes
we have those yeah just sitting there
with a hose to fill it up it's like they
give her water from a [ __ ] river you
might eat or build up they took a bucket
Ernie get the bucket we got folks coming
in for vacation um anytime you anytime
we just like a pontoon boat on a lake
his [ __ ] track right you're tying
boats together to drink beards [ __ ]
garbage yeah that was never you
no no no no we also I think that was
Indian like we didn't do family we
didn't uh family vacations as a thing
yeah I don't think I don't think there's
a large Indian population buying pontoon
boats okay did you have a super soaker
growing up if so what size 50 only after
50 I had a friend that had the 100 and
that guy with maybe had the 25 I think I
have the 25 with the regular the regular
rate of standard John yeah yeah but the
hundreds boy you were a king running
around running around the neighborhood
[ __ ] squirt and people parents
pranking them where was like tight you
couldn't go any further you're on the
handle and get sight I did have that I
had to backpack one I got for like a
birthday why never fight never [ __ ]
this [ __ ] rich kid [ __ ] our wheels
and backpacks this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
they would have never worked I would run
around with the 50 or whatever the 25
never worked to this day and it still it
bothers me every time I think about it
it bothers me if we wanted some [ __ ]
like that when I was a kid a [ __ ]
power wheel or a [ __ ] squirt gun with
a backpack you had a wind double there
that was the only way you will get mad
[ __ ] you had to compete for the [ __ ]
SPF 100 right now I'm gonna look them up
online see what I'm sure you can get you
can probably get one you know cheap
party all right
probably what do you got what do I got
did you guys would you guys celebrate
Christmas would you do anything like
that we would give gifts but that's it
and then my dad social tree one year and
think he uses [ __ ] for like four years
there was nothing left by the fourth
year and we put up this aureus light do
you ever see him like one spring of
lights that wasn't even like you know
and they're like kind of like nailed in
beautifully to the roof my dad just had
it up in town like a [ __ ] just to try
to fit in a little bit keep the eyes
just to tell everybody you're not Jewish
[Laughter]
I was just getting confused that's funny
dude you could always tell if at the
house on the block that really didn't
give a [ __ ] to who was just like this
one guy would just take his a string and
throw it over a tree and they would just
dangle one time and he told everybody
they were candy canes and he made those
every year trash yeah Christmas is a
[ __ ] dead giveaway man [ __ ]
colored light shitty tree [ __ ] up
ornaments garbage all right I think I
got one or two more here were you a Sega
Genesis or Super Nintendo kid growing up
I was Sega Genesis to be different yeah
yeah I was a big [ __ ] Sega guy I was
a Dreamcast I really what a Dreamcast my
antenna 64 I got it like a hundred bucks
but I loved it the thing that was
squared was a cube or something like you
have the remote with a little display in
it yeah it was a voice right but
everybody was so excited about
PlayStation 2 because I had a DVD player
that nobody [ __ ] a Dreamcast nobody
caught yeah it came out what beat I
guess between PlayStation 1 and 2 yes
yeah criminally underrated yeah I never
[ __ ] with it never my one buddy had it
he was trying to push it on see what
your dream castles core like dude get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
let's play some [ __ ] PlayStation
everybody was just I remember everybody
being like PlayStation 2 has a DVD
player and that at the time was like the
hot [ __ ] like that idea blew our minds
yeah of course yeah there was the lose
the Wild West for a little while with
game consoles till it all evened out I
hate it when it when there was like two
too many of them you're like
what's that like a period after that
they're like look we'll just make games
yeah did you have her have a TV with a
VCR built into it
no I actually I remember my sister came
home from college with one of those I
was like what in the [ __ ] woody where
you go to school NASA what the [ __ ] are
you from the future
I'm like you'll put that down on the TV
room baby let's get crackin inviting
some friends over those things were used
for one thing and one thing only
pornography was a [ __ ] mobile
whacking unit right there take that
thing into the bathroom run this turn
the shower on and get crankin I just
actually I just got two final questions
here we could just do them an order one
did you ever have a beanbag chair no man
I'd meet the people with a beanbag chair
and looking back was the stupidest
[ __ ] chair in the history of the
world it was it was garbage all the way
oh she's a fat kid they're not easy to
get out of oh yeah you gotta really you
gotta make sure everybody leaves the
room and you may get a really [ __ ]
roll out of there oh man get out of here
yeah it's tough
my firm question I'm sure it's gonna be
you know but you didn't have a racecar
bed growing up when you were a kid like
a chance did you
that's why you're garbage
I wanted one too so [ __ ] man I will
get my son a racecar bed i Prague here
why were they so cool in work I mean but
the second I saw one of them I'm like
never in a million years will I get that
what's not cool about it you gave me a
king-sized racecar bed I'd do that right
now I know man it's [ __ ] well I'm
sure I don't know why some company
hasn't came up with them yet cuz they
came out when our generation was coming
up so like everybody would [ __ ] have
them yeah that's a good point they need
that king size tempur-pedic racecar bed
that'd be sweet you know what else was
really sweet as a kid to bed was the
bunk beds that like crossed you want I
mean there was
one way and then the lower one went the
other way I didn't even know that
existed I was clean living
I'm never shopping for bunk beds we went
bunk bed shopping cuz we were thinking
about now it was me and my brother my
parents and I remember just knowing cuz
you see some [ __ ] bunk bed you're
like oh that's [ __ ] trash he just
knew you like we're moving into a whole
new level of garbage here you guys were
the coolest thing in the world to the
point that I convinced my friend to
convince his dead if he got all A's he
could get a bunk bed and I didn't
realize you're just sleeping on a
shittier bed and having a time oh wait
yeah way to do your bed that's a little
dangerous to be honest when you see it
on TV and you think it's amazing but
then you're on it no it sucks yeah
especially in the summer when your
[ __ ] two feet when you're two inches
away from the ceiling and the [ __ ]
hottest [ __ ] up there
horrendous oh my god good stuff I gosh
thing I gotta say miss kids clean no
garbage here baby I'm calling it a draw
I don't know I can't I mean he's got a
couple of blemishes but I mean you know
he's got the cinnamon toast crunch on
hand right now that's a [ __ ] that's
an A+ move that's classy this tercera
collection really really put some
[ __ ] yeah I use pretty good pretty
clean pretty clean thank you
buddy's anything you want anybody to
know out there what you got going on or
anything want to check out my podcast
flagrant two is gonna check out my
YouTube page the spelling of my name is
here you can just type it into YouTube
same with IG Twitter whatever check it
all out I'm gay I love it buddy thank
you so much kid we got anything got to
tell him yeah just make sure you rate
review subscribe on iTunes also full
videos up on YouTube you can subscribe
there we appreciate it
yep we've got our you garbage on
instagram @ H Foley on ice on Twitter
and at Foley Graham's on Instagram for
me again like Kevin said thank you guys
so much for appreciate you guys being
with this we'll be back next week Akash
you are the man we appreciate it buddy
thank you so much don't ya see anybody